zurück zu unserer eben erwähnten
ministerin für forschung und bildung
anja die analoge milchkanne carlitscheck
die hat nämlich gerade auch noch die ehe
für alle kritisiert sie möchte sagt sie
noch mal untersuchen lassen ob kinder
schaden nehmen wenn sie bei
homosexuellen aufwachsen hätte man nicht
doch eine forschungs ministerin nehmen
sollen die irgendwie aus der forschung
kommt man kann jetzt auch anders und
sehen man kann auch man kann sich auf
den standpunkt stellen wenn man sich
noch nicht auskennen stellt man
vielleicht fragen die ein anderer nicht
mehr fragen würde weil er sich schon
auskennt oder in der zeit wo man allen
mit seinem blöden fragen auf den sack
geht liest man einfach mal was schon
geforscht wurde zum thema kinder in
gleichgeschlechtlichen ehen herzlich
willkommen zu wissen macht das heute
schon forschungsmagazin mit künstlerin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da stellen wir uns mal janz dumm frau
carlitscheck möchte von der forschung
wissen kann ein junge der bei schwulen
vätern lebt trotzdem vernünftig fußball
spielen kann ein mädchen das bei lesben
aufwächst trotzdem gut kochen
ich glaube dass meine frau check aber
nicht doch im kern schon hast und das
ist ja eine klassische cdu position in
der alten union da geld noch dose auf
dose klappert oder wie man beim umbau
sagt gruber auch buben stinkt ich
erinnere an verdiente kämpen wie norbert
geis weil die eltern die ihr kind zur
adoption freigeben natürlich haben
wollen dass das kind in einer
vernünftigen gemeinschaft lebt nämlich
vater und mutter und nicht bei papa und
mama papa und manchmal aufwachsen totale
albtraum dieser hölle habe ich auch
durchgemacht ich auch ja frau
carlitscheck sagt zitat meiner
einschätzung als mutter dreier kinder
ist es das ist für die entwicklung von
kindern wichtig ist dass emotionale
spannungsfeld zwischen vater und mutter
zurück leben spannung es geht um
spannung wenn er vater zum beispiel die
mutter regelmäßig verwendet ist es
eigentlich gut fürs kind wegen
spannungsfeld was ist mit allein
erziehen kein spannungsfeld kinder
leider ballaballa
ganz so wegschmeißen frau carlitscheck
sagt sie stellt ja garnicht homosexuelle
unter generalverdacht sie fragt ja nur
eine offene frage es ist kein
generalverdacht
es ist eine bewegung die ich habe die
ich gerne mal unter forschungs
gesichtspunkten erörterte jahren zwar in
einer langfristigen ja endlich alle
langfrist studie die ihre wahrnehmung
bestätigt ist denn das zu viel verlangt
und dazu muss man wissen es gibt
tatsächlich dutzende internationale
studien zu dem thema in den usa läuft
eine schon seit 1986 und diese studien
kommen fast einstimmig zu dem ergebnis
dass sich kinder bei
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren mindestens
genauso gut entwickeln aber woher soll
die anja das wissen als
forschungsminister eben dazu hätte sie
die studien ja regelrecht lesen müssen
ja natürlich
da also nicht zumutbar der einzige
risikofaktor für diese kinder ist
diskriminierung durch gleichaltrige aber
das kann man sich direkt den eltern
vorwerfen sondern eher den arschloch
kindern in der schule wobei wir zugeben
müssen es gibt tatsächlich noch so
vieles was wir über homosexualität nicht
wissen präsidenten morales behauptet das
hähnchen mit pommes schwul machen ja da
bleiben ohne ende fragen was ist mit
ähnlichen ohne bonus das ist genug um
ist ich finde wir brauchen eine
langfristige aber herr süßkartoffel
pommes machen schon lesbisch ja ja klar
das wusste ich kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]